c'est ici que d'après Audrey Rémi aurait
surgi masqué et armée il était seul
de se retourner il a compris que ça ce
qui se passait c'est sûr qu'il a dû le
faire souffrir il a dû voir se venger
tout près
nous sommes sur l'étang de Thau à côté
de Sète dans l'Hérault
c'est ici que Marc vient tous les jours
travailler sur ses parcs à huîtres et
trouver un peu d'apaisement
car malgré ce cadre idyllique Marc ne se
remet pas de l'assassinat de son frère
Patrick il y a 3 ans
j'aurais jamais cru que lui il porte
comme ça quoi
c'était
jamais jamais j'aurais pensé
d'ailleurs quand je vous dis quand il a
disparu j'ai mais qu'est-ce qu'il lui
est arrivé il s'est trouvé au mauvais
endroit mauvais moment
depuis le drame culteur
à la mémoire de Patrick mort brutalement
à 49 ans
au Mas où il travaille avec sa fille
Nelly qui aimait beaucoup son oncle les
souvenirs sont partout ça
ça c'est lui et moi il avait 8 ans j'en
avais 13 ans
ça c'est mon frère avait mes filles et
sa fille et là c'est ça se passe le 15
juin il est mort le 23 le pont c'est la
dernière photo de votre frère ouais
c'est dur quand on remue beaucoup de
choses comme ça
après moi d'en parler on en parle après
bon voilà c'est pas des discussions qui
sont mais
c'est dur de tout remuer
il a été retrouvé ligoté abattu de deux
balles de fusils de chasse et en partie
calcinée dans une galerie souterraine du
Mont Saint Clair le crime ressemble à un
règlement de compte mais va prendre une
toute autre tournure quand deux ans plus
tard un homme et une femme sont arrêtés
un coiffeur c'est toi soupçonné d'avoir
agi par jalousie amoureuse et une jeune
femme qui aurait servi d'appât
pour certains le coiffeur n'en serait
pas à son coup d'essai il crie son
innocence
que s'est-il réellement passé dans le
huis clos de cette grotte retour sur une
affaire ou semelle vengeance et
machiavélisme et dans laquelle trois
familles se déchirent pour faire
entendre leur vérité
le 23 juin 2014 vers 16h15 Patrick Isoir
quitte son travail comme tous les jours
après son service à l'hôpital
avant de partir il a confié à ses
collègues qu'il a un rendez-vous galant
avec une jeune femme
il ne donnera plus jamais signe de vie
dès le lendemain matin son frère Marc se
lance à sa recherche et découvre son
scooter garé à côté du cimetière à
quelques centaines de mètres de
l'hôpital
le blouson son paquet de cigarettes le
téléphone
pourquoi partir en laissant ses affaires
dans la petite ville c'est
l'incompréhension
divorcé et perdent une petite fille
Patrick Izard n'avait aucune raison de
disparaître et pas d'ennemi connu comme
nous confirme Delphine sa meilleure amie
qui travaillait avec lui à l'hôpital
Patrick était connu
dans le centre
à la pointe courte il était aimé il
aimait jouer aux cartes il aimait jouer
à la pétanque il aimait faire les apéros
c'est un bon vivant à Sète personne ne
croit à une disparition volontaire de
Patrick
en cherchant dans son téléphone son
frère découvre un numéro mystérieux et
décide de l'appeler c'est une femme
[Musique]
m'a dit oh on est resté devant le
cimetière on a parlé puis on est parti
chacun
on est parti chacun d'un côté
la jeune femme avec qui Patrick avait
rendez-vous avant sa disparition
s'appelle audrey elle a 20 ans de moins
que lui c'est une ancienne conquête
Patrick et elle a vécu une courte
aventure six ans plus tôt
après des années de silence Audrey
venait tout juste de reprendre contact
avec lui flatter Patrick en avait même
parlé à son ami Philippe lors d'une
partie de cartes
c'est une femme ne voit très Mylène très
douce
qui me disait qu'elle m'aimerait bien le
revoir
en café
pour discuter Mani tu as pris ce coin
Julie
pas que le café
je voulais que tu me confirmes il m'a
dit c'est bizarre il me dit ça fait des
années que je la voyais plus et du joint
de mail m'appelle et elle me pose un
rendez-vous comme ça je comprends
sans nouvelles depuis 48 heures
marquisoire déclare la disparition de
son frère au commissariat une enquête
est ouverte
audrey est entendue et va donner plus de
précisions sur sa rencontre avec son ex
amant
nostalgie elle a proposé à Patrick de le
revoir lui fixant rendez-vous à côté du
cimetière
c'est un de ses amis proches Rémy
coiffeur à domicile qu'il aurait déposé
en voiture en allant travailler
elle aurait passé 20 minutes à discuter
de tout et de rien avec Patrick à côté
du scooter puis elle serait rentrée chez
elle
Audrey et Rémi sont les derniers à avoir
vu Patrick ils sont placés en garde à
vue face aux policiers ils sont
catégoriques ils n'ont rien à voir dans
sa disparition après 48 heures
d'interrogatoire il ressortent libre
plus tard le corps de Patrick Isoir est
découvert par les policiers au fond de
cette grottes en pleine ville à quelques
centaines de mètres du lieu de son
rendez-vous avec Audrey
alors là c'est l'horreur on pense que
voilà on est passé à côté de la grotte
peut-être
300 400 500 fois et qu'il était là et
que et qu'on savait pas
en apprenant les circonstances atroces
du crime ses amis sont sous le choc
et puis faire brûler le corps
c'est terrible
rapidement l'enquête s'oriente vers un
mobile passionnel les policiers
découvrent qu'en 2009 5 ans avant le
drame Patrick avait une liaison avec une
certaine Nadège l'épouse de Rémi le
coiffeur une liaison qui avait fini
tragiquement
car la jeune femme de 38 ans s'était
pendue après avoir avoué son aventure
extra-conjugale à son époux
à l'époque le mari de Nadège avait été
entendu par les policiers voici ce qui
est écrit dans le rapport
à l'époque Rémi avait déclaré aux
policiers que sa femme la veille de son
suicide lui avait avoué qu'au cours
d'une soirée arrosée entre collègues
elle l'avait trompé avec Patrick Izard
alors cinq ans plus tard le coiffeur se
serait-il venger de l'amant de sa femme
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la France en Normandie
sur la Côte de Nacre le père de Nadège
René chicard et son épouse Colette son
persuadés que Rémi leur ancien gendre
est un meurtrier
je te souhaite une joyeuses fêtes des
pères en espérant que vous allez bien
pour nous tout va bien je vous embrasse
Nadège
cette carte c'est la dernière qui l'a
reçu de sa fille 15 jours avant sa mort
les retraités sont persuadés que Nadège
ne sait pas suicider mais que ces Rémi
sont mariés qu'il a tué et a maquillé sa
mort en suicide
un des éléments qui les a le plus
troublés c'est le mot d'adieu que Nadège
a écrit à son époux avant de mourir ce
mot le voici
c'était pas une lettre de suicide
déjà une elle raconte seulement la
soirée qu'elle avait vécu et
comment avec Patrick isuart ce qui
s'était passé la relation sexuelle et
tout mais elle employait des mots mais
alors ça venait pas de Nadège elle
parlait pas du tout de sa vie rien mais
non c'est ça allez métro sa fille et
elle aurait dû elle aurait écrit si elle
s'était suicidée d'elle-même voilà
contrainte oui avant de ce qui s'est
passé oui autre chose choque René
chicard rémi a prévenu aucun membre de
la famille du décès de Nadège et la fête
incinérer cinq jours plus tard comme
pour effacer des traces compromettantes
selon lui
pour ma fille c'est un crime absolument
parfait
pendant des années René a tenté de faire
ouvrir une enquête sur la mort de sa
fille en vain
voilà toutes les lettres qu'on a fait au
tribunal de grande instance au procureur
au mois d'août au mois d'octobre
décembre janvier
tous les reçus
je pense que moi j'ai fait mon travail
personne n'a voulu m'écouter donc si on
m'a réécouté c'est sûr et certain que
Monsieur Isoir serait pas mort
à 7 les proches de Patrick Isoir sont
perçus à des de l'implication de Rémi le
coiffeur et de son ami Audrey dans
l'assassinat Marc
izoire multiplie les appels à témoin
dans la région et dans les médias et
l'un d'entre eux va relancer l'enquête
deux ans après les faits une amie
d'Audrey raconte aux policiers qu'elle
lui a confié avoir été manipulé par Rémi
pour entraîner Patrick dans la grotte
[Musique]
elle m'a dit qu'elle avait rendez-vous
avec Patrick pour qu'il accepte d'aller
dans la grotte elle lui a proposé de lui
faire une gâterie il a accepté en
arrivant de mettre la tendait
un autre élément intrigue les policiers
dans les relevés téléphoniques de Audrey
il découvre qu'à chaque fois qu'elle
appelle Patrick Isoir quelques minutes
après elle téléphone à Rémi le coiffeur
comme pour lui rendre compte de ses
conversations avec la future victime
deux ans après le drame Audrey et Rémi
sont interpellés et mis en examen pour
assassinat
il nie tout implication mais six mois
plus tard la jeune femme fait des aveux
à la demande du coiffeur elle aurait
entraîné Patrick dans un guet-apens
prétextant un rendez-vous galant
le 23 juin 2014 Rémi l'aurait donc
déposé au lieu du rendez-vous
elle aurait ensuite proposé à Patrick de
marcher jusqu'à la grotte
ils sont descendus et ils sont rentrés
directement dans la boîte
c'est ici que d'après Audrey Rémi aurait
surgi masqué et armée il était seul elle
ne parle plus d'un deuxième homme cette
fois-ci le coiffeur lui aurait ordonné
de partir elle n'aurait donc rien vu de
la suite de l'agression lui il attendait
il attendait moi je pense qu'il a
attendait le fusil quoi et dès qu'il a
il est rentré dans le dos s'il a eu le
temps de se retourner il a compris que
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
je suis sûr qu'elle a dû le faire
souffrir il a dû vouloir se vagir tout
près
depuis un an qu'il est InCar
Céré Rémi se dit innocent il affirme
qu'audrement et qu'elle s'est servi de
lui pour lui faire porter le chapeau
à 7 dans l'entourage du coiffeur on est
persuadé de son innocence
sa mère s'accompagne et sa fille ont
monté un comité de soutien aujourd'hui
ils sont une quinzaine à se réunir pour
eux le coiffeur est incapable d'un tel
machiavélisme
un thème a fait telle chose je vais me
venger jamais je vois pas pourquoi il
aurait été faire une abominable chose
pareille parce que c'est vraiment un
humeur
pour Laurine sa fille unique la
situation est particulièrement difficile
après avoir perdu sa mère à 11 ans son
père est accusé du pire
en soupçonne mon père d'humeur de votre
histoire et ensuite de ma mère alors
qu'il a complètement rien à voir on
avait il avait refait sa vie je
m'entendais très bien avec ma belle-mère
Céline on s'entendait tous très bien il
y avait rien à voir il peut pas avoir
fait ça quoi je me dis que là cette
année je vais faire mes 20 ans et dans
quelques mois il risque de pas être là
[Musique]
il y a un mois Audrey et Rémi se sont
retrouvés pour la première fois face à
face dans le bureau du juge à
Montpellier au fil du temps audrey a
régulièrement fait évoluer son
témoignage pour les avocats du coiffeur
c'est la preuve qu'elle a tout inventé
elle affirme des choses qui ne sont pas
possibles qui ne sont pas crédibles d'un
point de vue balistique c'est aberrant
ce qu'elle dit qu'elle ne voit pas de
fusil puis elle voit un fusil et non pas
elle n'entend pas de coup de feu elle
parle de deux complices elle parle d'un
noir d'un blanc
il est venu avec un masque un masque de
Scream pour se cacher on est dans un
film c'est le film d'Audrey Louvet il y
a absolument rien de crédible dans tout
ça pour l'avocat de la jeune femme en
revanche sa cliente a été utilisée à son
insu c'est une fille simple qui n'est
pas du tout évidemment une tortueuse
compliquée ni d'un niveau intellectuel
exceptionnel c'est le contraire de
quelqu'un qui manipule aurait qui
imaginerait des scénarios un
vraisemblables et Audrey
tout simplement voilà elle était là pas
qui a permis de
conduire ce malheureux à sa destination
finale
l'instruction est toujours en cours
à ce jour l'assassinat de Patrick Isoir
conserve toujours une part de mystère
[Musique]